[Applaudissements]
être maîtres transmettre il ya quelques
mois je suis monté sur scène pour la
première fois de ma vie en suivant un
instinct une intuition qui m'amenait
exactement là où j'avais oublié que je
voulais aller petit j'ai voulu faire à
peu près tous les métiers du monde
mais mon plus grand rêve c'était d'être
chanteuse donc à 18 ans je me suis
inscrite en classe préparatoire
économique et social
henri iv hec postes à responsabilité des
parents étaient hyper faire mais moi je
me suis aux billets jusqu'à un point de
non retour
ce moment vous savez au fond de vos
tripes que c'est la mort ou la vie mais
sans vraiment choisir porté par un élan
qui me dépasse j'ai choisi la vie ici et
maintenant j'ai choisi d'écouter mon
intuition
même si je ne comprenais absolument pas
pourquoi elle me dicter mots par les
scènes jetez y un peu plus d'un an et me
vollard ce soir devant avec la joie et
le plaisir de vous partager la plus
belle leçon d'humilité et de sagesse que
j'ai apprise sur scène être maîtres
transmettre habitants je suis devenu fan
connais tu es mais moi je me suis dit
qu'avec une belle voix forte puissante
on peut toucher le monde entier et puis
à 30 ans j'ai été ému aux larmes par une
musique
[Musique]
e
ibrahim et après des années de musique
classique
j'ai enfin intégré dans ma chair que des
notes de musique seuls peuvent déjà
touché nos coeurs et puis à 30 ans
toujours cette année où j'ai enfin
décidé de me laisser guider par mon
intuition
j'ai été bouleversé par une performance
de l'artiste
marina abramovic
silence et j'ai pris conscience que le
silence peu touché nos âmes être maîtres
transmettre mais si le silence dit déjà
tout qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya rien à faire pour exister
je me suis demandé pourquoi comment si
c'était vraiment possible
alors j'ai lu j'ai investiguer les
sciences les arts les philosophies des
sagesse ancienne mais la réponse m'est
venue sur scène chaque soir après le
show en parlant avec le public
je me suis rendu compte que chacun
entend voix et reçoit un spectacle
différent comme passer par un filtre
votre propre filtre celui de l'instant
du moment du juste message prêt à entrer
en résonance avec une partie de vous
avec votre âme
ce que je joue ce que je chante ce que
je danse n'a aucune importance
ce qui s'échange contre le public vous
ce soir et moi sur scène c'est une
vibration
et bien au delà des mots cette onde que
j'aime et en parlant vois pas de danse
ou alors en chansons on voit une
information à tout votre corps que vous
interprétez et qui est en train de
générer chez vous un sourire un frisson
une larme une idée une pensée une prise
de conscience
son écho est différent pour chacune et
chacun d'entre vous essais libres à sion
qui émane de moi elle n'est que le
reflet extérieur d'une profonde
intentions intérieur
cette attention à ma porte et dès mon
plus jeune âge dans les premières
chansons j'écrivais jusqu'à ce soir
devant c'est une intense vibrations
d'amour est en flammes pour moi être
artiste
bien plus qu'un métier c'est un état
d'esprit un état d'être que chacune et
chacun d'entre nous peut embrasser dès
ce soir c'est mon invitation prouve
soyez artistes de votre vie quel que
soit votre métier
quelle que soit votre activité osez
décidé assumé de poser une intention
vibrer l'amour sur ce chemin
le silence est la juste actions sont nos
alliés nous ressenti deviennent nos
guides
oui je me sens bien j'avance non je le
sens pas j'hésite je fais un pas de
recul je me lève je prends de la hauteur
et je tends l'oreille un massage s
intérieur ce mariage parfait entre mon
intuition mon intellect et toutes mes
formes d'intelligence car je sais que ce
que j'offre au monde
quand je me sens bien à ma juste place à
un impact décuplée
tout autour de moi avec cette incroyable
prise de conscience il n'y a qu'à être
pour émettre et transmettre s'est
écroulé derrière moi le monde et il faut
des jeux doit défaire comme de la peur
qui paralyse de la norme qui conforme
pour s'ouvrir à moi un univers dans
lequel mon seul absolue ma vérité et
être qui je suis à chaque instant et
tant que c'est le cas
mes paroles mais je laisse mes actes
et donc mes rencontres mais échanges
mes créations sont en parfaite résonance
avec mon intention initiale alors si
vous aussi vous avez envie d'être
artiste de votre vie je vous propose de
tester dès ce soir votre tout premier
tpm ppp oui c'est facile c'est pour ça
que c'est marqué au tableau tpm ppb tout
petit mini prochain pas possible vers
votre plus grand rêve le plus fou
apparemment pour moi ça a commencé avec
ce carnet
ce telle action la moins engageante la
moins flippante la plus secrète que je
pouvais faire vers l'idée de peut-être
un jour monter sur scène pour quelques
années
quatre mois plus tard je vais me one
woman show pour la première fois et
aujourd'hui
j'enregistre mes premières chansons
alors vous voyez je crois que la vie
peut nous surprendre
aujourd'hui je suis même persuadé que ça
nous aider à réaliser nos plus grands
rêves
si on se donnait une chance de réaliser
notre rêve collectif mais plus fou créer
un monde d'harmonie et de paix se
rappeler que tout ayez communion pour
moi c'est l'une des plus belles
intentions de notre âme
c'est l'alchimie qu'on ressent dans des
concerts dans des stades de foot c'est
l'émerveillement
on peut ressentir en contemplant un
magnifique paysage ou en savourant un
délicieux repas
c'est ce moment de pure magie qu'on peut
vivre dans un opéra à massy
28 novembre ça commence par toi par toi
par toi partout parfois par toi parfois
par nous tous ici ce soir
en posant une intention oui à l'heure où
va vrai show woman who we r who we love
love love we à le et vous qu'est ce qui
vous fait vraiment vibrer merci
[Applaudissements]